city lights was released in 1931 and was
written and directed by Charlie Chaplin
it also stars him this was a major
passion project for him and something
that he worked on for many years if you
guys aren't familiar with Charlie
Chaplin he was one of the biggest stars
of the silent film era his character the
Tramp sometimes known as The Little
Tramp or he would sometimes refer to him
as little man this is a character that's
synonymous with the silent era was one
of the most famous at the time and one
that Chaplin had portrayed in various
films and short films and Chaplin's
choice to make city lights as a silent
film despite the fact that Hollywood had
begun to move towards the talkies was a
divisive one because people felt at the
time that talkies were going to take
over and of course they did but Chaplin
was of the belief that silent films were
really what filmmaking was all about in
the talkies they would die out in a few
years but I think his real motivation
for making this a silent film was that
he wasn't very comfortable with the idea
of this character that he created
existing in a talkie he didn't think
that the character would be as funny
because it's a character that relies a
lot on pantomime and expressions it's
very physical lots of sight gags a lot
of things that he does in this film are
a bit like a dance so he was afraid that
this character would not work in a
talkie and he may have been right and
nevertheless we have city lights as a
silent film and I would say it's
probably my favorite silent film this is
a movie about Chaplin's famed character
the Tramp who meets a blind woman who's
selling flowers he quickly becomes
infatuated with her and has to try to
court her without her finding out that
he isn't rich and when the Tramp
befriends someone who actually is rich a
drunk man who's trying to commit suicide
and he keeps him from doing that their
roles switch quite often and he gets the
opportunity to have access to things
that only a wealthy man at the time
would have like a car or money to buy
flowers from her and so now we have a
moral dilemma
he loves this girl she likes him back
but she thinks that he's rich and he's
really not city lights is one of my
favorite romantic comedies if you were
to call it that in many ways it has
influenced all romantic comedies that
have come since then especially in its
final scene
I have seen countless films with a
moment so similar to the way this film
ends that you can understand why so many
people credit Chaplin for showing
Hollywood how to make films or how they
can make films that are financially
successful while also being critically
successful because this film was both of
those things Albert Einstein came to the
premiere and we still have a photo of
that today and so you can tell that
Chaplin was definitely someone that
people were paying attention to at the
time he was already famous by the time
this movie came out but the idea of
making a silent film once talkies had
been introduced reminds me of how Alfred
Hitchcock decided to make psycho black
and white in 1960 even though colorized
films were popular at the time he wanted
to make a film that was black and white
because he felt that that approach to
filmmaking had more merit behind it had
more suspense to it he could get more
things out of it than he could from a
film that was shot in color but what's
inescapable about this film when you
watch it today is just how damn funny it
is from scene 1 I'm laughing my ass off
there are so many sequences that are so
simple the things that he's able to do
with this character a boxing match in
particular this dance that everyone's
doing highly choreographed and very well
rehearsed it's just so goddamn hilarious
and that's Chaplin he was such a
perfectionist a lot of people when you
think of a perfectionist filmmaker you
instantly think of someone like Stanley
Kubrick who was definitely a
perfectionist Chaplin may have been even
more so history has shown us through
various interviews with cast members of
this film people involved in the
production and documentaries about it
that he would shoot sequences far more
than other people would he would do shot
after shot take after take to try to
achieve something that was in his head
he would sometimes jump into other
actors roles and perform the sequence
exactly how he wanted them to do it
there was quite a bit of on set tension
between him and star Virginia charile
because the way Chaplin worked he shot
this film over the course of a couple
years and he was such a perfectionist
about making everything as good as it
could be that some of his actors
including Jarrell were getting antsy and
he actually fired her at one point
reshot parts of the film with someone
else before eventually rehiring her
again this is not the type of filmmaking
that could be done today
Virginia charile today in 2018 would go
on her Twitter and say Charlie Chaplin
just fired me and it's horrible and you
know Charlie Chaplin would be faceless
with so much pressure from social media
and the news world to be a better person
perhaps that's a good thing but in the
long run his incredible OCD
perfectionist brain made one of the best
films of all time and so you have to
wonder just at what point did Charlie
Chaplin go overboard or did he go
overboard by firing people and rehiring
people and then firing them and rehiring
someone else did he go overboard or was
he just trying to make a perfect movie
in the way that he felt he could it's
interesting to view old Hollywood versus
new Hollywood and I read about the
production i watch interviews i watch
documentaries and I realized that if
this exact film was being made today it
would be very controversial in the way
he handled himself on the set but it
resulted in a great film and one that is
timeless because nowadays there's a bit
of apprehension when you sit down and
watch even a black and white film kids
today they don't want to watch movies
that are old like that even some adults
don't want to watch older films let
alone a silent film one that is told
entirely through pantomime music and
some sound effects this actually does
have some sound effects there's a
hiccuping whistle scene there's some
sort of like almost like Charlie Brown
talking in the background where some
people are like a crowd in the beginning
are chanting and it's like it sounds
like almost like a kazoo
that was actually Charlie Chaplin making
those sounds which makes it the first
time Charlie Chaplin's actual voice was
ever heard in a film they're going back
to that apprehension that people have
about watching a silent film I think
it's gonna be boring or that it's not
going to have any action sequences or
anything to invest you in but from the
beginning of this movie consistently I'm
laughing
in particular the scenes with Harry
Myers who plays the eccentric
millionaire this guy only recognizes the
Tramp when he's drunk when he Sobers up
in the morning he's like who are you get
out of my house
it creates some really hilarious
sequences one of the best moments in the
whole movie is watch how you're driving
him by driving the guy is literally
behind the wheel Chaplin and his cast
have crafted a silent film that is
drastically funny extremely well shot
and still holds up today as a film that
has clearly influenced tons afterwards
his sight gags the slapstick his stunt
work his actors are all fantastic this
film is a labor of love for sure if you
ever read into the production and a lot
of people argued and it was a long time
coming for Chaplin but the end result is
a classic that has stood the test of
time and if you've never seen city
lights or if you've never seen a silent
film before this might be a really good
one to start I'm gonna give city lights
and a plus guys thank you so much for
continuing to watch my series of pre
1970s reviews I went way back with this
one that I wanted to talk about a silent
film for sure this year you guys are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching and look forward to more if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]
you